[Musique]
pour la cinquième année consécutive le
département accueille une délégation de
jeunes malgaches
ils sont neuf tous lycéens avoir
remporté le concours national de france
est une action qui marque l'engagement
du département dans l'appui à la
francophonie à madagascar
et lorsqu'il ya ici mais on leur
concocte aussi un programme un programme
de visites
il découvre la réunion il découvre les
sites patrimoniaux de la réunion et
principalement les sites patrimoniaux du
département bien sûr et il ya cet
échange cette couverture qui permet aux
jeunes à travers la langue française de
porter des projets
or son pays en l'occurrence ici pour
madagascar
mais ce format est développé dans tous
les pays de la zone océan indien
des lycéens engagés dans l'apprentissage
du français pour décrocher ce voyage à
la réunion ils ont remporté la
compétition nationale de théâtre en
langue française sur une pièce des
précieuses ridicules
pour nous la loi c'est l'image de la
france donc la france dans l'histoire
c'est cette primaire de madagascar c'est
comme une nuit
une coopération culturelle riche
d'enseignements pour ces jeunes
malgaches qui très certainement seront
demain les ambassadeurs de la langue
française dans leur pays
[Musique]